CORRESPONDENT JENNIFER
GRIFFIN TELLS US WHERE WE
STAND RIGHT NOW FROM THE
PENTAGON.
GOOD EVENING, JENNIFER.
>> GOOD EVENING, BRET.
THAT NATIONAL SECURITY
MEETING STARTED NOT LONG AGO
AND INVOLVED THE DEPUTIES
INSPECTORS FOR THE
ORGANIZATION OF THE
PROHIBITION OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ARRIVED IN SYRIA
TODAY.
AND TOMORROW HOPE TO BE ON
THE GROUND IN DOUMA WHERE
THE ALLEGED ATTACK TOOK
PLACE.
BUT IT'S NOT CLEAR THE
PRESIDENT INTENDS TO WAIT.
AN EMERGENCY MEETING AT THE
U.N. SECURITY COUNCIL TODAY
WHERE U.S. AMBASSADOR NIKKI
HALEY LAID BLAME FOR SYRIA'S
ACTIONS ON RUSSIA.
>> IT IS RUSSIA ALONE THAT
USED ITS VETO SIX TIMES TO
PREVENT THE CONDEMNATION OF
ASSAD'S USE OF CHEMICAL
WEAPONS.
IF RUSSIA HAD LIVED UP TO
ITS COMMITMENT, THERE WOULD
BE NO CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN
SYRIA.
AND WE WOULD NOT BE HERE
TODAY.
>> THE UNITED STATES
ESTIMATES THAT ASSAD HAS
USED CHEMICAL WEAPONS IN THE
SYRIAN WAR AT LEAST 50 TIMES
SINCE THE WORLD FIRST TOOK
NOTICE IN 2013.
ESTIMATES ARE AS HIGH AS 200
TIMES.
>> WE'RE, AGAIN, CONFIDENT
THAT BOTH SYRIA HAD
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS
CHEMICAL WEAPONS ATTACK BUT
WE ALSO HOLD RUSSIA
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR
FAILURE TO STOP CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ATTACKS FROM TAKING
PLACE.
>> BRITAIN AND FRANCE SAY
THEY HAVE THE EVIDENCE.
>> WE HAVE PROOF THAT LAST
WEEK NEARLY 10 DAYS AGO THAT